[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mac here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime newscast
links are in the description
recommendations goal in the comments and
first right off the bat I want to clear
something up for all you Code Geass fans
the alleged new image of Code Geass
season 3 or r3 that was supposedly
leaked over the weekend and that
appeared in a video by Fox and and
amount Saturday is a complete fake
that's right everybody this was just
photoshopped and it was most likely
photoshopped by Fox and anime himself
now many of you realized that he posted
this video on April 1st and you just
assumed that it was an April Fool's joke
and I personally have no problems with
April Fool videos as you may know I
actually posted on April Fool's video on
Saturday as well and it was a video
about a yuria Nights live-action
adaptation starring a sumo wrestler in
the leading role so obviously everyone
knew that was a joke the issue with the
Fox and anime video is that he nowhere
actually admits that it's a joke and he
took great care to actually Photoshop
this image and he did it in a way that
would confirm certain theories certain
popular theories about what is actually
going to happen in code geass season 3
and for that reason a lot of people were
fooled again I'm nothing against Fox and
anime or these types of videos but as an
anime news channel that covers the
latest in code geass season 3 news a lot
of you guys reached out to me on discord
on Twitter on Facebook in the YouTube
comments and you were asking me why am I
not reporting this huge Code Geass image
leaked why am I not on top of this news
and for that reason I wanted to clarify
this is a fake this is not real news
this image is photoshopped it cannot be
found anywhere else on the Internet it
did not blow up on Twitter like Fox and
anime claims and you can even find the
original images that he used in order to
make the changes that make it look like
this is a new image a leak of r3 in this
original Lelouch image as you can see
there is no code mark on his chest
it was just added afterwards and there
are a whole bunch of other red flags in
this image including the fact that the
Japanese letters above Anya actually
Merry Christmas so why would this image
be leaked in April
I want to thank Alondra and potato from
the discord server for helping me out
confirm that this is a fake and yeah
guys don't be fooled by this it was just
an April Fool's video not real news in
other news I want to talk a bit about
the YouTube advertiser boycott which has
been rocking the YouTube community as of
late if you don't know basically the
Wall Street Journal the same paper that
went after PewDiePie and failed to take
him down decided to go after YouTube and
Google Adsense as a whole and basically
what they did was they searched YouTube
for videos that might appear offensive
so videos with things like the n-word in
the title and they look to see if they
can find any of those videos actually
monetized actually making money from ads
now there are billions with a/b videos
on YouTube and they managed to find a
few that were in fact offensive and
apparently had ads placed on them so ads
for big companies like Coca Cola
Starbucks and so on so what these guys
did The Wall Street Journal reporters
sent these screenshots to all the media
and to all these companies and basically
pressure them to boycott YouTube to
boycott Google Adsense Adsense and to
actually withdraw from the Adsense
program now can you imagine how
difficult it is for YouTube to monitor
billions of videos so of course a few
unfortunately slipped through the cracks
and the Wall Street Journal jumped on
this created a witch-hunt where they try
to portray YouTube and Google as a whole
as racist and they use this as a way to
get back at YouTube and at PewDiePie for
not being able to take them down to get
back at the YouTube community for
standing behind PewDiePie after the Wall
Street Journal slandered him took him
out of context and just did some really
scummy terrible terrible journalists
work unfortunately many of the big
companies took the bait they caved
completely and pulled out of YouTube
advertising and this has decimated the
revenue of the vast majority of
youtubers and I mean decimated for
example here on this channel we are
making less than a third of what we
would have been making in a dreary
before the boycott but we were never
making much to begin with so it's not a
huge loss for us but the people that I
really feel bad for are those
medium-sized youtubers who might have
quit their job and started doing YouTube
full-time who are maybe making about a
thousand dollars a month which is not
that much just enough to pay the bills
but they're hoping their channels are
going to grow and they're going to make
more later
and now overnight their income has gone
from a thousand dollars to like 250 a
month how are they going to pay their
bills how are they going to support
their families it's completely insane
like I said I do this for love I do it
because I choose to and there is
absolutely no reason to feel sorry for
me I already work on the side anyway if
I have to work on the side more I will
do that that's not a problem
and I will continue to put out videos I
might not be able to make quite as many
but I'll do my best to make as many as
possible because I love doing it I love
interacting with you guys and creating
this awesome community and some of you
guys have actually been donating to our
live streams using the YouTube super
chat without us even asking you to it is
crazy it is totally unexpected thank you
guys so much off the top of my head I
know double the rebel made a bunch of
the nation's I know Gilgamesh donated a
lovely tune that I donated on Hunter
Valley donated and even our boy bricks
from all day anime thank you guys so
much
it is much appreciated and because of
that because some of you guys have been
donating even though we never asked you
to even though we never expected it I
decided to set up a patreon account for
the channel where we can actually reward
you and show our appreciation for your
donations and also because patreon gives
a lot more percentage to the actual
content creator from every donation then
YouTube does if you do want to support
us on patreon you can check the link in
the description I think we set up some
really cool tiers that a lot of you guys
will appreciate but remember it is an
honor just to have you guys watch our
videos and be a part of this community
so please don't feel pressured into
anything we do this because we love it
and we're going to keep doing it no
matter what in anime uh pro news over
the weekend we actually hit 10,000
subscribers everybody thank you so much
that is a huge milestone
your support means a lot to us the
community that we built is amazing and
it just
motivates us to keep going harder and
faster than ever before this past
weekend also mark the start of a brand
new anime season the spring 2017 anime
season which included the releases of
attack on Titan season 2 and my hero
academia season 2 here on the channel
we've been experimenting with doing a
live reaction slash discussions of some
of the new anime and over the weekend we
actually watched attacker Titan season
two and also in a separate video the
iron blooded orphans season finale where
we basically launched the stream through
OBS studios had a timer up so that you
guys could watch the anime along with us
and discuss it with us in real time in
the chat and then right after the anime
was finished we discussed it our first
impressions things like that and it was
a lot of fun so we're going to continue
doing this for attack on Titan season 2
and my hero academia season 2 every
single episode from now on you can
expect those every Saturday as close as
possible to the release date for the
anime in Japan as we can get so be sure
to tune in come hang out it's got to be
a fun time this April first was
definitely an interesting one here on
YouTube as I said we had our own yuria
nights live-action movie April Fool's
video that you should check out if you
haven't already and also our rant cafe
crew made a whole bunch of new videos
we had Brynn from Bryn's fandoms make an
ASMR video we had cyanide blizzard make
his own ASMR video and we had Mackel not
make a roast of the anime community and
in this roast he even mentioned a
channel called anime uproar so that was
quite interesting be sure to check those
guys out and speaking of cyanide
blizzard he has a brand new first
impressions video out this week on
attack on Titan
season 2 be sure to check it out and
this one even features a cameo from Eno
from our discord server so Ino is
quickly becoming a voice actress great
job Ino great job cyanide be sure to
check out that video the link is in the
description and my favorite a MV for
this week was a reason
AMD called killer
by evolution a in these this is a really
well done video it brings out the dark
themes of re0 quite well my only issue
with it is that it focuses too much on
the RAM and Subaru relationship and not
on Amelia who is my best girl but I'm
sure the RAM fanboys like ANBU and soul
maka will love this one so be sure to
check it out and that is it for this
week guys if you enjoyed these videos be
sure to LIKE and subscribe and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]